okay so let's stick to the political
component of all of this can you just
help me define some of the terms for
people that don't understand so there
there's Islam the religion then there's
there's Islamism there is jihadism
there's a couple other terms in there
can you lay out sort of the important
the important ones and and why they're
important in the distinctions between
each one you know I don't use Islamism I
use the term political Islam and the
reason is is I define political Islam
very precisely one of the things you
have to do in science is precisely
define what you're talking about in
mathematics is that is really half the
job so what I want to do is to discuss
the political aspect of Islam which
affects me now then that means that
jihadism is part of political Islam and
by the way we need to step just to the
side here and point out that jihad is
not just your heart of the sword it's
also jihad of the mouth jihad of writing
and your heart of money so jihadism can
take more forms and manifestations and
you might think the muslim brotherhood
for instance more seizes upon the jihad
of the pen the mouth and the money
whereas al-qaeda an islamic state sees
more upon the jihad of the sword it's
just we need to understand that there
are more forms of jihad than you might
suspect well so so when people talk
about radical jihad or violent jihad
that that's really we're just talking
about we're talking about blowing things
up beheading people the killing and all
that stuff but really you're you're
linking that to the rest of this and
that's that's where the dangerous
combination is if you were only Johanna
the sword we actually wouldn't have a
problem I don't need to minimize the
death of 3,000 people but we kill more
people than that with hospital care lack
of hospital care and drunk driving on
Saturday night again I do not want to
minimize the suffering of the death of
people that come under violent jihad
sure it's just that the actual numbers
that are killed are not enough to change
America but changing the textbooks that
changes America so the jihad of mouth
and speech and money is far more
important than your heart of a sword
right so that there is what you're
talking about with the textbooks that's
the 25-year plan that the Muslim
Brotherhood had
John and and that's jihad not in the
traditional sense that we think of it
and then there's of course there is also
the violent component to it
oh very much so but for instance against
me I've never had violence practiced
against me but I've had whole smear
campaigns launched by Islam so therefore
look jihad does not mean holy war hard
means war jihad means struggle and so
therefore it is an effort writing a
letter to the editor defending Sharia
can be an act of jihad so John is John
is actually it means it's a
civilizational war look Islam is so
shrewd they use food let's take the
hijab well that is a form of jihad in
the sense of you now are shaping the
uniforms requirement at saving the
police department well it just moved it
a little more into Sharia compliance so
the jihad is very subtle civilizational
war i'm argue that mohammed was the
greatest warrior who ever lived in
humanity who dies today for Alexander
the greater Julius Caesar no one someone
died today Oh Dave because of jihad yeah
therefore it's a very it's very powerful
concept so the hijab comparison I think
is really interesting because I see this
all the time where where my friends on
the Left who are supposed to be for
women's rights in equality and minority
rights and all of these things they are
in every other case but for some reason
when it comes to the hijab or the burqa
which is far worse as Bill Maher calls
it a beekeeper outfit you know any mean
for some reason their hands off on that
that's the one that they say well we
can't really tell these people what to
do and yet you're supposed to be for
women now I understand that there are
women that that are probably watching
this that are wearing a hijab and it is
their choice or at least they believe
it's their choice but is this really a
failing of the left that that's very
much how I see it
who you know it is very interesting and
Bill Maher is a courageous man now I say
that based on a very few YouTube videos
let me confess I'm not I don't watch TV
now I realize man well
when I saw the second plane hit the
second tower I stood up and said Islam
is here it is jihad and in that moment I
turned off the television and I saw that
all of my life study of religion was now
going to come into play that I would do
nothing but explain to my fellow
citizens what Islam really means so
that's and I've lost my train of thought
well I think that well related to Bill
Maher so there's a there's an
interesting piece of that because there
aren't many people that are honestly
discussing this right we have Sam Harris
and there's some X Muslims and there's
there's you and there's GAD and a few
other people and then because of that
because of the lack of discussion around
it we keep handing the conversation to
people that come in with easy answers
Allah Donald Trump ban all Muslims so
that that's really why I wanted to have
you on to discuss this stuff because
you've put yourself on the line related
to this and and as you said you haven't
been attacked physically but it doesn't
come without cost to talk about this
well I just returned from a talk in
North Carolina I gave it Sunday there
were protesters outside the president of
a local college said that I should be
banned from speaking there were protests
from many people that I should not be
heard so and by the way I would like to
say that doesn't affect me at all but
knowing there are hostile people in the
audience does affect me it's just that I
suck it up and go on yeah but so what
were they protesting I they were
processing saying that you were using
hate speech I'm guessing or something
along those yes who as a matter of fact
you might be you may want to turn the
set off right now this whole exercise
that you have been sharing is an
exercise in hate speech Islamophobia
racism that's the oddest one what has
it's Lomb got to do with race I finally
figured it out racist is just the worst
word they can use an open conversation
on TV day if you were on the street
they'd use another word right and all
they're trying to do is insult you right
and that's and that's the chilling
effect because nobody wants to be called
the race a racist right and and once the
items I don't either and I'm not a
racist and you know as Douglas Murray
who you may be familiar with the the
British author I've had him on the show
and he basically has said these people
are so ill intentions
with their insults that we can't pay any
mind to them anymore and I think that's
that's pretty much what you just said
the only one I paid in in mind - I never
defend if you call me a racist that's a
sure communist llama phob right the only
one that I defended myself against was
not the charge of being unstable by the
college president but the fact that I
should not be allowed to speak and
that's when I've actually had challenged
him to a debate I said bring out your
best scholars and we will debate the
following thesis there is no good for
the Catharine political Islam see how
did you real easy topic sir all you have
to show one good thing so piece of cake
let's do it and I want a free and open
discussion and that means that I'm not
going to call you a racist a hater an
islamaphobe the I try not to interrupt
people when they talk I try not to raise
my voice and I try not to ever insult
because I don't want those things for
myself and yet I find that the left this
is what they do
I would love to debate a leftist on the
subject of political Islam I don't have
any problem that at all I do have a
problem being called racist hater
explana phone bigger yeah yeah also but
I don't try to deny it I've learned it's
like a car baby if someone calls you a
racist
islamaphobe hater bigoted it's like
don't even go there because how do you
deny you're already you're fighting on
their terms yeah what I try to do is to
move it to facts I mean I love that and
that's literally everything that I do my
show about is to is to let's talk about
the facts here let's not get lost in all
the feelings and let's not sling all
these these words at each other that
that killed the conversation
interestingly people have asked me
they've said well why don't you have
some of these apologists you know some
of these well-known Western apologists
people who have probably said plenty of
unpleasant things about you why don't I
have them on my show and I one of my
responses is first off if some of them
want to come on they're welcome because
that just as you said I will debate if
they want a debate or I'll interview
them if they want an interview but what
my main issue with it is that many of
the bigger players in this space have
proven themselves so dishonest time and
again that it ultimately becomes a waste
of mental energy for people like us
right if you were to debate someone that
you felt was so Mis intentioned what's
the point
the end of the day well we could at
least try I mean I'm willing to give you
three strikes let's let's give it a try
yeah but I think we do have to learn how
to discuss these issues and think it's
not just these issues there's issues I
want to step off just a side path here
because it has affect us at Vanderbilt
University which is my undergraduate
school here in Nashville Carol Swain
made a remark which he said was
politically incorrect
it was trauma for the students it was
front page news in the largest newspaper
in Tennessee the president of Vanderbilt
said we'd fire her but we can't because
she's tenured then here's the critical
thing they established a psychological
hotline for those students who were
traumatized about hearing an idea that
they were offended by Dave my question
is how do I get on this short list of
people who cannot be accessed well
listen as a as a white man that as a
cisgendered white man and I could
probably think of a couple other buzz
words you're you're in a lot of trouble
you're not going to be on any of those
lists I've noticed this yeah you're not
going to show you're on okay so for the
nominal Muslim for the average person
who doesn't necessarily believe in the
book literally but enjoy some of the
traditions some of the food some of the
family aspects of this sort of like most
Jews in America are basically secular
but enjoy some of the holidays and
traditions and things of that nature
what's the outreach plan for these
people because these are the people
we're supposed to be trying to get right
well I always like to bring up the
subject of Mohammed and to discuss the
life of Mohammed it's very interesting
to ask questions of a Muslim to see what
they know about Islam the most
astounding thing is usually you find
they don't know anything to speak of at
all when I was in Munich Germany a
Muslim was standing there who identified
himself as Muslim and he had a beer in
his hand I said is that beer halal now I
asked him I said are you familiar with
the Sunna of Mohammed and he was sort of
quizzical as you know the hadith the
Sira have you read those no I said if
you read the Quran all of it he said
well no but I have an uncle who's a
mullah I said we don't need the mullah
we need Mohammed
you need Mohammed so I'd love to ask
Muslims questions about what they've
actually read and do you think that's
any different than the average Jewish
person or the average Christian I find
most people and again that goes to why
what I'm talking about religion on the
show it's like so many people really
want to move past it however because of
the political element and the violent
element that's going on right now it
makes it almost impossible to do well I
want to talk about it I'll talk about it
with you I'll talk about it with a
Catholic priest I'll talk look I'm kind
of like I used to be young believe it or
not when I was young if you want to talk
about sex I was all ears but now that is
a little bad I'm all about Islam so I'll
talk about it with anybody and so that's
what I try to do and and by the way I do
talk about it with Muslims I've debated
with Muslims just had you know
conversations so I think that Islam
political Islam is an incredibly
fascinating topic and so I've devoted my
life to talking about it because the
answer to Islam is Islam I tell people
to cut a dime and you need a diamond and
to cut Islam you need Mohammed and by
the way notice what I said there forget
about the Quran it's too difficult to
read and it was deliberately made
difficult to read but anybody can
understand the life of Muhammad so start
with Muhammad and once you know Muhammad
actually feels soldier through his life
you'll discover that you can read the
Quran and understand it just knowing who
he was yeah so going with the with the
political part of that when these
discussions happen you know a lot of
people will say well look what America
has done in the name of imperialism or
capitalism or whatever now granted
America has done a lot of bad things and
even as we speak right the second there
are drones flying over you know Pakistan
and Afghanistan and if they kill some
innocent people while killing terrorists
well I can understand why people
wouldn't like the West and you know
there was the Ottoman Empire that ran
the whole Middle East and then the
British Empire carved it up and the UN
carved it up in all kinds of crazy ways
so a lot of them will say well if all of
that happened and you happen to be a
certain religion your religion would
become sort of intertwined with the
political part of that
do you think that's a fair critique no
it's not a fair critique at all it wants
to take Islam only is that an event that
happened since colonialism we want to
remember the United States was has been
in existence a very short period of time
and what I like to point out is the
origins of Islam or what hit it's its
roots and the origins of Islam are based
on expansion by sword remember in the
history of Muhammad's life the religion
of Islam did not bring him success but
the politics of Islam through jihad
brought in complete success this
happened in the year 632 when he died
this was a little bit before Europe was
the power it is now and it was a little
bit before so we need to have an
explanation about Islam that will
include all this long not just what
happened since the colonialism of the
Europeans in the Middle East that is we
need answers which explain everything
and the answers about the doctrine
explain everything what happened in the
Middle East today and what happened
1,400 years ago so what do you make of
the fact that so many of the attacks
that we see in the Middle East I mean
just in the last couple days you know
bombs blowing up all over Iraq Iraq
which is now at this very moment seems
like it's crumbling worse than its
crumbled in the last 10 years I mean
these are jihadists that are blowing up
mosques so did not they happen right
there's a there's a form of jihad which
i call joe hama jihad of purification
may give an example when Muhammad died
the first caliph was Abu Bakr which
actually is the name of the current
Calif of Islamic state there was not an
accident
and so when Muhammad died a whole lot of
Muslim says you know the Islam thing's
been kind of cool but we're out of here
Abu Bakr says not so fast you can't
leave so therefore the first war fought
by Islam was the Reta Wars which are the
Wars of apostasy so this is what happens
in the very beginning so because of that
basically you're saying that that on any
of these given attacks they can just
look at the there's ways that they can
look at the other and say that they're
not quite the right antic they're not
authentic so therefore this is jihad of
purification
mystical study based on the raw data
found in the religion of peace calm and
what I discovered was is that for every
kafir who dies in Jihad there's roughly
two Muslims this is over the period of
the last job I think since 9/11
so therefore the person most apt to kill
a Muslim is surprised not a drone but
another Muslim but they're killing them
for authentic for reasons of
authenticity they're hypocrites or
they're apostates they're not good
enough Muslims in particular Islamic
state is Sunni and they'll kill the
sheet on a heart beat yeah so let's
that's exactly where I was gonna go
actually can you explain a little bit
about the difference between Sunni and
Shia because we have strange alliances
here in the United States with different
regimes depending on whether they're
Sunni or Shia like our friends I suppose
the Saudis it's very very confusing as
to what's going on with them but can you
explain what the difference between
Sunni and Shia is first let me say the
difference makes no difference let's
start with that questions really moved
here's why remember I'm not about
religion and I'm about the politics that
affects me right you see the Shia say
that the Caliph should only be a
defender descendant of Muhammad and in
particular Ollie whereas the Sunnis say
that any man who follows the Sunna and
Sunni is capable of being Kayla so this
is the distinction but it really goes
back to bad blood between different
political elements in Muhammad's day but
why do I say it doesn't make any
difference to me because the Shia and
the Sunni have a doctrine of jihad
against the kafir they have a doctor to
the session so in the critical elements
that which affects me I'm like who cares
right so far from my point from my
viewpoint I can't tell the difference
what do you make of the Christian
community right now the political side
of Christianity that is watching
Christians all sorts of sects of
Christianity being kicked out of the
Middle East communities that have
existed there for thousands of years
being kicked out right now by Isis and
all kinds of other groups and holy sites
being destroyed left and right and
they're not saying
anything what does that tell you about
the political state of Christianity
bankrupt morally bankrupt I stand in
churches and condemn them for saying
you've lost the ability for righteous
anger your your own scriptures teach you
that you're to take care of the
persecuted and yet you will do nothing
why would you do nothing because you
don't want to be called a bigot and a
hater you have reduced all of
Christianity down to two syllables be
nice but let me tell you something Jesus
was not a nice man he was a kind man
that he was capable of debate he was
capable of argumentation he was capable
of offending the powerful so you need to
stop this niceness and become a follower
of who you say you are
what a wonderful distinction that is
because people think you know what would
Jesus do and it sort of be nice but
you're really making a great point there
he fought the power he did he did the
right thing if you believe in historical
Jesus he did the right thing but that's
but that's different than just being
nice
oh well listeners and finally I have
nothing against being nice at a steady
diet of nice is like having the buffet
have nothing but ice cream pie candy
cake and chocolate on it it's like yes
it's like nice is the dessert you need
it it's nice but you need much more than
that now I read by the way when I
condemn Christians always follow up with
this parenthetical expression
I'm only condemning 95% of you which how
do they take that when I'm with a small
smile or you condemn them and they're
stood in their own church and I've said
the Christians have become a people who
are kind compassionate loving caring
sensitive but without courage I said you
have only compassion you have no courage
and this is not the way to be in the
founding of this nation Christianity was
a civilizational force but now that I
tell them your influence no longer goes
beyond your parking lot yeah I mean
that's really a fascinating thing and I
guess the proof in that is that if you
were to look at the nation's that are
majority Christian pretty much in all of
them people of all religions are allowed
to live peacefully without having
religion imposed on them not to say we
don't have hardcore fundamentalist
Christians here who do get in by
in politics and of strong Christian
right which fortunately in America is
getting less powerful but basically you
can live in a Christian nation as an
other and be okay but that is there any
example of that in an Islamic country
where you can live as another and truly
be equal well let's just take a let's
just want the turkey used to be
Christian North Africa used to be
Christian Egypt used to be Christian
Afghanistan used to be Buddhist Pakistan
used to be Hindu Persia was even half
Christian where is that Christianity
today Malaysia used to be hinted where
is that Hinduism today who is Hinduism
found in Pakistan so I'm giving you
different examples now what they say is
as well you know whether we can live in
harmony but how does it work out in
history and what it works out in history
is is I call it the law of Islamic
saturation once Islam enters a society
and the Sharia starts taking hold it
will over enough period of time become
completely saturated with Islam yeah was
it you that had laid out certain
percentages of these things where if
they hit certain like four percent or
someone else did that it sounds like my
work and I'd love to take credits work
but I cannot yeah I was somebody did it
I'm not sure who well somebody will tell
us in the comment section sort of laying
out percentages and saying you know
certain population points hit certain
changes that then change things
societally and in terms of laws and
things like that it's very much in your
line of thinking I think yes and it is
true the more Muslims are there the more
Islamic the society becomes and the more
demands they make upon that society yeah
so so let's be clear here to wrap this
thing up because in in the 50 some odd
minutes that we've been talking I
haven't sensed one even slight twang of
bigotry or certainly not racism or
xenophobia or Islamophobia because as we
said it's it's a made-up word from you
and yet I know what people will say
about you and I know what people will
say about me just for just reliving
station now yeah exactly so jump but
just for having this conversation
so I guess my last question to you is
what is the bet for the average person
that's watching this
that here's you and that wants to do
good and may have Muslim neighbors that
they're friends with and may be married
to a Muslim person or whatever it is
what's the best way that you think the
average person out there that cares
about this can help spread this message
that you're spreading which really is a
peace and equality but it's dealing with
some some tough stuff well I'm an
educator and what I say is you have to
educate yourself now you can use my
books or other books but you must learn
the life of Muhammad not the fake
biographies that are put out like by
Karen Armstrong with something based on
the serie and maybe that's my message no
Mohammed and you need to understand what
the Sharia is the Sharia is far more
subtle than you think and we need to
resist any further advance of Sharia and
we do this what knowledge of who
Muhammad is who he was and therefore we
don't want the progression that was with
Muhammad which was from peaceful
religion to violent politics well there
you go I hope that even my friends on
the Left who I disagree on this will be
able to watch this and say okay that was
an honest conversation and let's try to
have some some difficult discussions but
I'd love to have you back in a couple
months and we'll go sure about this
because you're there's so many we barely
got into anything we haven't we haven't
discussed women's issues we have we
haven't even started well we did I do
all we do a whole show on Mohammed in
the Jews yeah I mean we did an hour we
basically did about what we did 30
seconds on women I don't think we said
the word gay once we really did 30
seconds on the Jews all right so you
will you will definitely come back yes
as you can tell I enjoying these kind of
conversations I'm after all this is what
my life is welcome to my life well I'd
like to thank dr. bill Warner and for
more on the work he does you guys can
check out political Islam calm thanks
again dr. Warner